I
don't regret what I did to
that person that day,
thank you.
It's cute, it's
open to the public It's
disgusting It was an invitation,
I got the root of it Ah, it's the first time I've felt this kind of feeling
If I do something that makes the city song sad
, I'll stop cheering It's the first time I've ever done this
Feeling like I don't really understand, please put me in the shade It
's my problem, so I don't have a humanities in my budget
Ah ah ah
me
I think I'm the one who applies to this person My name is
dark Please let me be dark Ichika-san's troubles are mine I'm a normal child but I
guess I'm special to my brother
If I say that I wanted a favorite, I'll get angry if I say that I wanted a favorite